[Music]
no matter who you are high school is the
same it's the best of times it's the
worst of times full of wonderful people
and not so wonderful people my school
kind of sucked for us move on we know
that there has been some bad blood
between us but there is no reason why we
can't finish off the school year being
sick Wow
small fifteen crush your enemies totally
so we're free we are going to stand up
for ourselves how exactly are we going
to do that all we have to do was
convince the outsiders snippets and
weirdos of the schools to band together
where you're proposing is like the Rebel
Alliance why do we have to tie finders
there see sci-fi and totally different
neither do you get laid right yeah
these files represent the entire student
body
he is figuring out what makes people
tick
then exploiting it mercilessly I like
you Virginia
even if you are named after a slave
state
oh and you there you're going to be
popular we're actually thinking more
along the lines of revenge
like honk on here anyway Bluto not only
house that will house the school
thinking that they were my equal man
which white people are messed up
thank you for honest my mom says never
come to a party empty-handed oh my god
we are diversify our high school
experiences already
you